hey guys love the show like everyone
else
and um
the show introduced me to the book so i
was wondering how many of you guys ran
home after the filming of season one to
find out what happened or how familiar
you guys were with the source material
i know what happened
david and dan are you familiar i was
shocked
[Music]
shocked
um yeah well
after after the my after my first
audition i got the first book and um
devoured it in in not too long at a time
and then was obsessed with it and was
ready to move on to book two but wanted
to be with i wanted to be with danny as
as we were filming season one so i was
very much like i mean my seriously my
copy of the first book is like taught
it's got all my notes in it's you know
like kind of was my bible for a really
long time and then my celebration of
wrapping season one was starting book
two so i'm kind of gonna go like as that
yeah i'm yeah i'd really all i want to
do is just read ahead but i'm trying to
paste myself so i know where i want to
yeah
when i read the first book uh
and i had um i locked myself up for like
four days actually read it it was blown
away and uh
like right when it came to me dying
i just like
so loved
out of here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
bring him back
all right we have another question
it's actually related to something you
just said
mr martin why is it you're always
killing off people's favorite characters
well it keeps you on your toes
no you know i've always believed that uh
i want people emotionally involved in my
story and when they're in a dangerous
situation
just as you'd be in life if you were in
a dangerous situation i want the readers
to be
almost afraid to turn the page not
knowing who's going to win who's going
to die
i mean we all know books and movies
where
you know the hero may seem to be in deep
trouble but you know he's going to get
out of it because after all he's the
hero or they are the heroes if there's a
group
and those shows are fun but
they don't really
involve your emotions and that's what
i'm looking for
[Applause]